mauvais temps sur toute l'europe en
france la tempête a fait plusieurs
victimes et des dégâts matériels
importants mais c'est un vent chaud qui
soufflait températures sont largement au
dessus de la moyenne il a fait 24 degrés
à perpignan aujourd'hui et partout
ailleurs entre 12 et 20 de retournement
de l'histoire l'exil et bjarne riis à
carole sera enterré demain à moscou
entouré de tous les fastes officiel
michael gorbatchev doit présider les
cérémonies lyon genève sans arrêt l'auto
qui sera inaugurée demain supprime le
trop célèbre bouchon de nos emplois dix
ans de travaux pour presse kilomètres de
tunnels et de ponts une entreprise de
titan et un prix à la mesure 140
millions du kilomètre
le cinéma ne vient de perdre l'un de ses
derniers cowboys de légende lee van
cleef vient de mourir à l'âge de 64 ans
son rôle de prédilection celui du
méchant
madame monsieur bonsoir l'actualité de
ce dimanche soir est avant tout
métérologiques qu'il a fait non
seulement une après midi mais une
véritable journée de chiens et cela sur
toute l'europe
seule consolation des températures qui
en france dépasse est aujourd'hui
partout 12 à 15 degrés jusqu'à 24 à
perpignan mais la tempête qui a soufflé
de la grande bretagne à la france en
passant par l'espagne a fait
malheureusement plusieurs victimes en
seine maritime un homme a été emporté
par une vague alors qu'il se promenait
le long de la côte
hier c'est un caméraman de fr3 qui
avaient été emportés de la même façon
près de brest à aubervilliers cet après
midi deux hommes ont été tués par un mur
qui s'est écroulé sur eux et sur un
terrain de golf de la banlieue
parisienne
un bâtiment s'est effondré faisant une
victime et trois blessés graves
le tour d'europe du mauvais temps
valérie faune l'europe de l'ouest
victime d'une perturbation venue du sud
de l'atlantique avec des vents allant de
100 à 150 km heure une perturbation
pourtant classique douce et humide
allons de l'espagne jusqu'aux îles
britanniques
car cette tempête n'est pas exceptionnel
mais une mer particulièrement déchaîné
alors que les températures sont
printanière voilà de quoi surprendre
en espagne on déplore déjà trois morts
et les dégâts sont importants des 10
arracher des bateaux éventré et à
l'intérieur des terres le vent a même
baptisé de petits feux qui se sont
rapidement transformées en de véritables
incendie au portugal dans l'embouchure
du tage près de lisbonne
les sauveteurs ont tenté toute la nuit
de sauver un homme resté bloqué dans une
barge ils ne le retrouverons
malheureusement pas vivant en france les
sapeurs-pompiers de l'hérault recherche
encore le propriétaire d'un voilier qui
s'est échoué hier au soir à palavas en
bretagne dans cette zone au large des
côtes du finistère un marin irlandais
portés disparus après le naufrage hier
au soir du cargo arc l'eau victor à
quelques milles de là le navire espagnol
julio del mar est resté en difficulté
pendant près de 24 heures
il a perdu une partie de sa cargaison
dont la nature n'a pas été communiquée
les 21 marins présents à bord n'ont pu
être hélitreuillé que cet après midi en
dépit du vent qui soufflait à 150 km
heure toujours dans le finistère à l'île
de sein trente maisons inondées après la
destruction par les vagues d'une digue
de protection
et puis hier en fin d'après-midi jobic
delage journaliste reporter cameraman à
fr3 film est pour vous cette tempête sur
le port du conquet
ce sont ces dernières images que vous
voyez une vague géante l'a emporté lui
et le véhicule en région parisienne à
villennes-sur-seine un vent de terre
s'est engouffré sous un préau où 20
personnes sont traînés au golf
bilan un mort et neuf blessés à
aubervilliers deux passants ont
également été tuées écrasées sous un mur
détruit par une rafale de vent
le vent toujours et encore à saint
pierre de port près de fécamp
un promeneur a été emporté par une vague
les recherches sont pour l'instant
restées vaines
en grande-bretagne enfin la tempête fait
rage aussi sur la côte les habitations
comme les bateaux n'ont pas été épargnés
ce reporters dépêchés sur place en
cornouaille dira même que les anglais
n'ont pas vu cela depuis 50 ans cette
tempête qui couvre l'europe et qui sait
pour l'instant assagi reprendra demain
de plus belle l'histoire maintenant avec
tous les bouleversements qui s'opèrent à
l'est prend de tels virages qu'on reste
saisi par les vérités d'aujourd'hui qui
ne ressemblent en rien à celles bière à
moscou par exemple le physicien andreï
sakharov qui vient de mourir sera
enterré demain avec toute la pompe que
s'est déployée le communisme pour ces
héros on annonce même la présence de
numéro un soviétique monsieur gorbatchev
aux obsèques de celui qu'il faut
rappeler jusqu'en 1985 était considéré
comme un pestiféré un exilé dans son
propre pays
reporter corps une perte
le peuple d'abord et venus en foule une
après midi entière
ils sont là pour rendre un dernier
hommage à celui qu'on appelle déjà un
fin
des fleurs des larmes de l'émotion au
delà des différents la classe politique
également a salué unanimement la mémoire
d'henri sakharov et la bonne heure sa
compagne tous les combats a reçu les
condoléances des députés progressistes
aux conservateurs ils reconnaissent en
lui la fatique ap défenseurs des droits
de l'homme pour son fils dimitri si le
peuple peut ainsi rendre hommage à andré
sakharov
c'est que ces idées commencent à faire
leur chemin dans les mentalités
soviétique
mais avant tout s'ils sont là à attendre
dans le froid pendant des heures c'est
pour se faire pardonner de l'avoir
laissée seule dans sa lutte il s'excuse
qu'il t'excuses ceux qui l'ont humilié
vous pensez bien que personne ne devait
s'excuser
il nous faut nous excuser nous devons
nous faire pardonner sans lui ça va être
dur n'était le contre-pouvoir du parti
il était le père de la perestroïka
il était le premier dans les années 60 a
parlé de la coexistence pacifique
demain après midi andreï sakharov
reposera à jamais dans un petit
cimetière loin étant d'officiel mais le
peuple est déjà persuadé que sans sa
lumière
l'avenir de l'urss sera plus en
allemagne de l'est a reçu ce week end la
visite du président de la république
fédérale celle de l'ouest monsieur
vanackere et du ministre des affaires
étrangères de rfa monsieur guen ch
préparant tous les deux la venue cette
semaine en allemagne de l'est du
chancelier ouest allemand monsieur
helmut kohl
dans le même temps le parti communiste
est-allemand qui tente de se raccrocher
aux événements comme il peut a tout de
même donné un sérieux coup de frein
certes il a symboliquement accroché
aujourd'hui et les mots socialisme
démocratique à son sigle mais en même
temps les journalistes présents à ce
congrès ont bien senti que sur le
problème d'une éventuelle réunification
des deux allemagne et bien les
communistes de rda était plus que
prudents reporter philippe roesch brian
k
l'une des nombreuses révolutions au sein
du parti communiste est-allemand val
terrien cas ancien ministre de la
culture condamnés à l'exil est
prisonnier après les événements de en
veillant 56 est appelée à siéger dans le
groupe des sages du parti un parti qui a
dû trouver des compromis
seul le nom de son chef gregor ghisi
fait l'unanimité après un discours de
trois heures où il a expliqué les
dangers de la réunification que les
frontières entre les deux allemagnes
tombe avant que l'unité européenne ne
soit réalisé commencera alors dans toute
l'europe le débat sur les frontières
sera menacée et les allemands seront de
nouveau mis en cause
tout cela après deux guerres mondiales
nous avons le devoir de ne pas laisser
faire une nouvelle déstabilisation
étonnant de voir que les anciens
dirigeants comme egon krenz démissionner
était là et que nous avons pu les
interroger sur les visites en rda de
helmut kohl et françois mitterrand et le
chancelier kohl doit prendre en
considération ce que vient de dire le
parti sur la souveraineté des deux états
allemands la politique intelligente de
françois mitterrand doit conduire à ce
que la france et la rda contribuer
ensemble à la stabilité et à la sécurité
en europe
un grave côté de la draft
si j'arrête d'europalaces
prudence du premier ministre moudre ou
face à la volonté de réunification
il doit être clair des deux côtés que la
réunification n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour
c'est pourtant à la réunification que
pensaient les 2500 délégués du parti
communiste qui se prononceront au
printemps prochain sur le programme de
renouveau du pc est allemand en
tchécoslovaquie maintenant dans la
capitale prague des milliers d'étudiants
ont manifesté en cette fin d'après midi
de dimanche en faveur de l'écrivain
contestataires vaclav havel qu'il
voudrait voir porter à la présidence de
la république tchécoslovaque
ils ont manifesté sur les lieux mêmes où
avait eu lieu leur premier défilé le 20
novembre dernier à l'époque la
répression de la police avait été sévère
depuis vous le savez tout a changé et
non pas seulement dans la capitale la
décommunisation s'accélère comme le
prouve cet événement symbolique survenu
dans une localité de 2000 habitants à
peine à 60 km de prague
les habitants de cette ville de cette
bourgade ont décidé de se débarrasser en
vendant de se débarrasser de la statue
du petit père des peuples autrement dit
staline qui trône est là depuis 42 ans
avis aux amateurs reporter christophe
martet andris il a régné sans partage
sur le monde communiste est aujourd'hui
plus de trente ans après sa mort staline
continue d'imposer sa présence au petit
village de komarov auto qui vit ici
depuis 42 ans a assisté à l'inauguration
de la statue en 1951 déjà à l'époque je
n'étais pas tellement d'accord mais la
différence c'est que je ne pouvais pas
le dire
ce sont les ouvriers de cette usine
bouzou look qui avaient spontanément
nous dit-on offert une journée de
travail pour le petit père des peuples
les en cette période de démocratie
renaissante ils sont bien prêts à vendre
cette statue en devises
puisqu'on leur a dit qu'à l'ouest elle
pouvait trouver preneur pour le maire
tout doit quand même passer par un vote
on n'a pas encore reçu d'offre pour
cette statue n'est de toute façon cet
ouvrier décidé puisque c'est eux qui
l'ont payé comme au hasard avec atg et
au delà ce serait une bonne chose de
recevoir cet argent on pourrait
l'utiliser pour le bien-être des à
distance ça permettrait peut-être dit
des crèches ou d'améliorer la vie de nos
personnes âgées je pense qu'un site où
le village peut être d'en profiter
ce serait un juste retour des choses aux
bottes
aujourd'hui la population de komarov est
bien décidé à prendre sa revanche sur
l'histoire
elle attend des propositions de
collectionneurs qui pourrait la
débarrasser de ce symbole encombrant
alors avis aux amateurs l'actualité de
ce dimanche c'est encore à l'étranger le
retour à la démocratie au brésil avec le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle bruno le dreff dans tout
le pays de longues files d'attentes
ce matin les brésiliens se sont dépêchés
de voter non seulement parce que c'est
obligatoire sous peine d'amendé mais
aussi et surtout parce que pour la
première fois depuis 29 ans ils élisent
leur président au suffrage universel
face à face deux hommes fernando collor
40 ans représentant de la droite
populiste et luiz inacio da silva dit
lula
44 ans du parti des travailleurs il
représente la gauche après un mois d'une
campagne acharnée
les sondages indiquent une élection très
serrée fernando collor n'aurait qu'un à
deux points d'avance les deux candidats
jeune et charismatique s'appuie sur la
majorité pauvre du pays
sur 82 millions de votants on compte 20
millions d'analphabètes qui participe
pour la première fois à une élection et
sont plus que d'autres sensible à la
bocca da orne à la bouche d'urnes qui
autorise la propagande orale à
l'intérieur même des bureaux de vote
une tradition qui laisse peser le
soupçon sur une partie des suffrages
une seule nouvelle d'importance dans
l'actualité politico judiciaire de ce
dimanche en france la mise en garde à
vue du vice président de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de nancy
monsieur bernard fois c'est interpellé
dans le cadre de la sphère des fausses
factures qui hier avait vu l'inculpation
et la mise en prison du maire rpr de
tout le vice président du conseil
général de meurthe-et-moselle monsieur
gosso le début de la faire je vous le
rappel des grandes surfaces qui pour
s'installer dans la région ont dû verser
de l'argent en sous main aux hommes
politiques personnellement ou aux
caisses de leurs parts
l'inscription le dire la fin d'un
bouchon ce sera pour demain dans la
région de nantua dans le département de
l'ain 13 km d'autoroute par comme les
autres qui ont nécessité des travaux
gigantesques et bien un permettront de
relier enfin à lyon à genève et de
desservir les stations de sports d'hiver
des alpes sans les fameuses encombrement
qui chaque année blocs est à cet endroit
des milliers de vacanciers pour ne
parler que de dix ans de travaux ont été
nécessaires et le coût de construction
des kilomètres d'autoroutes s'élève à
140 millions du kilomètre reporter de
lisboa hier pascal puis viaducs tunnels
viaducs tunnels ce sont les ouvrages
d'art de ce tronçon de 13 km de
l'autoroute à 40 qui termine enfin l'un
des plus grands axes routiers français
ouvrant la porte des alpes de la suisse
et de l'italie
ouvrage d'une haute complexité puisqu'il
a fallu dix ans d'ingéniosité d'efforts
pour en venir à bout
à tel point que le président de la
république l'a baptisé l'autoroute des
titans
août se développe sur le versant de la
vallée donc sur la la pente d'éboulis et
ses boules y sont relativement épais
puisque pour ce viaduc en particulier il
a fallu traverser 35 mètres d'épaisseur
pour aller chercher le gros saule
pendant dix ans 700 personnes ont
travaillé sur ce site
cinq d'entre elles ont payé cette
réalisation de leur vie un million de
tonnes de béton ont été coulés les murs
de soutènement couvre une surface de 100
mille mètres carrés coût du kilomètre
d'autoroute 140 millions de francs
on a quand même dû déroger dans bien des
cas pour faire passer l'autoroute pour
l'inscrire dans un site aussi la suite à
l'école de par ses difficultés
tenant évidemment la topographiques et
qui est accidenté quand vous l'avez eue
mais à une géologie frères ont tourmenté
aussi mais dans le jura dans des
terrains calcaires les infiltrations
d'eau qui sont abondantes donc les
tunnels sont étrangères une feuille des
temps shit un véritable imperméable qui
est mise en oeuvre par la blement
bétonnage et qui nous garantit des
tunnels c'est comme vous l'avez vu une
étanchéité nécessaires au bon
fonctionnement d'un système électronique
qui place cette portion d'autoroute sous
haute surveillance les caméras des
indicateurs de pollution dirigent leurs
informations vers ce pc sont prises 24
heures sur 24
toutes les décisions concernant la
ventilation l'éclairage des tunnels les
panneaux d'affichage et enfin la
circulation
cette gigantesque aventure est achevée
et tout le monde est content les
automobilistes mais surtout les
riverains de la nationale 84 et les
habitants de nantua
donc tu as été une ville véritablement
traumatisé sinistré par la circulation
automobile
une ville où la circulation est fluide
permet aux éventuels clients aux gens
qui sont de passage de s'arrêter on ne
s'arrêtait plus à nantua parce que non
tu as était le bouchon de noctua c'était
l'endroit où les automobiles se
suivaient les unes derrière les autres
ou pour s'arrêter c'était tout un
problème et on préférait aller plus loin
quand on fait une telle ées clients
payent pour dormir et on a eu souvent
des clients qui descendait le matin ils
nous disaient vite vite ma note j'étais
aux 24 heures du mans
c'est certain il y aura une baisse de
profits
la route la plus attrayante et plus
tonique
tellement qu'elle fera sûrement une
pratique pour l'autoroute a40 enfin
terminée sera ouverte dès demain la
circulation avant l'inauguration par le
ministre de l'équipement et des
transports ce lundi un petit coup de
balai s'impose prix du péage mâcon
genève 43 francs bonne route
médecine maintenant avec une nouvelle
vraiment d'importance dans le dépistage
du cancer pour certains types de cette
maladie du moins des chercheurs
israéliens viennent de mettre au point
un détecteur capable d'un diagnostic en
moins d'une heure tel aviv
charles enderlin cette technique va
peut-être révolutionner la détection
d'un certain nombre de cancers
tout commence avec une banale prise de
sang un groupe particulier de globules
blancs les lymphocytes est séparé des
autres cellules sanguines coloré avec un
produit fluorescent et placés dans ce
réceptacle
il est constitué d'un grillage
microscopique où les lymphocytes
occupent chacun leur place comme ses
balles de ping-pong l'examen peut
commencer
il s'agit de détecter les lymphocytes
qui auraient été en contact avec une
tumeur s'est réalisé grâce à des
réactifs spécifiques de chacun des
cancers étudiés jusqu'à présent du
poumon de l'intestin de la peau du sein
et sous le rayon de ce laser les
globules blancs répondent leur signal
est enregistrée au travers du microscope
cellule par cellule
il y en a des milliers le tout dure un
peu plus d'une demi-heure 2000 tests ont
été réalisés avec une exactitude de 98%
des résultats qui ont stupéfié les
spécialistes le professeur weinreb qui
dirige l'équipe de chercheurs de
l'université bar ilan à tel aviv estime
que l'appareil
le site ozcan peut conduire la recherche
médicale vers de nouveaux horizons
peut-être des diagnostics très rapide de
compatibilité lors de transplantations
d'organes le site ozcan va être produit
en série par les industries
aéronautiques israéliennes
il coûtera un peu plus
un million de francs un prix qui devrait
le mettre à la portée de la plupart des
grands centres hospitaliers
le cinéma en deuil encore après la mort
de silvana mangano la mort d'un cowboy
l'acteur américain lee van cleef vient
de mourir d'une crise cardiaque à l'âge
de 64 ans engagé volontaire dans la
marine américaine pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale il avait ensuite connu
le succès avec le train sifflera trois
fois suivi de la célèbre série des
westerns dispac'h des petites de sergio
leone contrairement à gary cooper ou à
john wayne
il était lui le plus souvent le méchant
nicole cornu langlois et est il bon
etait-il brut
etait-il truands difficile de savoir qui
était le véritable lee van cleef temps
ces personnages de western était devenu
micky et que cacher ce visage dur
cette stature de virilité à ma cible le
jeune lee van cleef connaissait mieux
les sous marins et les dragueurs de
mines que les studios de cinéma
remarqué dans une troupe de théâtre
amateur il tourne son premier film en
1952 c'est le train sifflera trois fois
de fred zinnemann il est l'un des
bandits dompté par gary cooper
mais c'est sergio leone qui lui donne
une renommée internationale avec pour
quelques dollars de plus
en 1965 et le bon la brute et le truand
en 1966 il a joué dans quelques 350
films téléfilms plus ou moins bon aux
usa en europe et le dernier au japon
faites attention
mais c'est sur la californie qu'il a
jeté son dernier célèbre regard d'acier
dans les i dans la série des
informations parfois un peu bizarre que
l'actualité du dimanche vous laisse le
temps de développer ce soir inattendu et
imaginative l'idée de la municipalité
d'hagetmau dans les landes comment faire
d'un handicap un avantage une curiosité
et des créations d'emplois en même temps
reporter henry bodiguel aimé mayol quand
on dispose d'une eau qui jaillit
naturellement à 33 degrés quand on
dispose du plus grand abattoir de toute
la région
et quand on doit payer au refroidir
l'eau et faire disparaître les déchets
de l'abattoir pourquoi ne pas imaginer
que ces deux handicaps en les
additionnant devienne un plus et
pourquoi pas les rentabiliser sous la
forme d'un élevage de crocodile c'est le
projet pour le moins insolites proposés
par le maire d'hagetmau un sa commune
quand on pense à saïda vent on parle de
permis crocodile en train de griller
dans les rues d'alger de boer bon c'est
pas de cas il faut savoir qu elle est
co-présidée c'est en fait de
l'aquaculture c'est à dire les cocos
l'île sont élevés dans des bassins et
dans des bâtiments fermés dans des
bassins à 29° puisqu'ils doivent d'avoir
29 degrés l'ordre et chauffer santé
ratures et qui pour nous n'est pas un
problème si notre oseille apprend
progrès et deuxième chose dans des
bâtiments qui eux mêmes sont à 29 degrés
seuil et par conséquent que les
crocodiles ne se verront pas il faudra
pénétré dans les deux bâtiments pour
pouvoir les voir
il y avait aussi la solution des
vautours qui ont la spécialité de
dévorer tout ce qui traîne mais dans une
région où on est habitué à des volatiles
du domestique est aussi plus comestible
c'est quand même la solution des propos
des pollueurs qui s'est imposé non sans
réticence d'ailleurs quatre mille
visiteurs par jour
j'ai pris ça comme ça si ça peut amener
une très bonne idée pour tension c'est
qu'en mettant des lacets ya un croco
d'un mètre on enfile une paire de
souliers et qu'on lui collant des
poignets dans le lot on en fait un sac
un tel projet a priori ne se refuse pas
si le projet coince encore aujourd'hui
c'est à cause de quelques indigènes qui
refusent de voir transformer leur mare
en marigot de crocodile city il faut pas
oublier que sur des animaux qui mangent
deux fois par semaine et qu'il mange
quand ils en ont envie
donc vous voyez un petit peu les odeurs
les insectes et cetera ce qui ce qui
peut apporter comme comme ce que ça peut
apporter comme nuisances se calment
l'inconvénient du crocodile us
mississippi ainsi c'est son nom c'est
aussi qu'il traîne derrière lui une
collection de terreur qui remonte au
fond d 'argent et il faudra sans doute
patienter pour voir la ville d'hagetmau
devenir un jour reco landes
voilà je crois qu'on n'a rien oublié
dans cette affaire le théâtre dans le
théâtre qui n'est pas réservé à paris ou
aux grandes villes c'est ce que se sont
dit il ya six ans eh bien les habitants
de monclar 900 âmes lot-et-garonne
monclar qui organise régulièrement
depuis 24 heures de théâtre 80
spectacles sans comédiens un véritable
marathon pour tous ses acteurs
nous avons suivi l'un d'entre eux qui
interprète des rôles en une seule
journée reporter nathalie dollé bernard
collin
un kilo il y en a trois de ses comptes
en banque tout que pour cette infamie et
me suis je peux aussi dans les travaux
perrier que pour voir on les paie d'un
mois première étape de cette force de
fonds pour nicolas briançon le cid
puissance est et rhône pour lancer 24
heures de jeu non-stop
alors ils courent ils courent d'une
salle à l'autre d'un rôle à l'autre en
trois minutes de 6 il devient poète ou
écrivains emprisonnés
si demain la vie permise
des noms qui sur ce mur se brise
nous serons hinault mot de passe
à pied à vélo à cheval
tout est bon pour passer de la petite
cave au grand chapiteau en traversant le
village
changement de lieu changement d'époque
nicolas se transforme pour le début de
soirée en haïti bios et joue les
troyennes de riz deep et nicolas lui
repart pour de nouvelles aventures il
lui reste six rôles pour jouer jules
renard il devient maurice un dandy du
19e siècle
bonjour en l'air mais la performance est
calculée à la minute
le tout est d'arriver à l'heure pour sa
propre scène même si le spectacle est
déjà commencée gouvernement
il était loin du saloum pour l'is ou
vraiment l'ex le salut du peuple est la
loi suprême et la loi du théâtre veux
qu'il continue même au petit matin seul
le souffle inspiré d'un public comblé
après 24 heures peut faire s'écrouler
l'équipe des baladins voilà et avant de
passer aux sports nous vous parlions pas
lors des élections présidentielles au
brésil les premières depuis le retour de
la démocratie dans ce pays
et bien selon les premières estimations
qui tombe à l'instant monsieur color
représentants de la droite dite
populiste serait en tête serait donc élu
mais c'est encore officieux pardon
président du brésil
le sport donc maintenant les allemands
de l'ouest vainqueur de la finale de la
coupe davis il menait 2-1 avant le
simple qui opposait cet après-midi
becker à wilander il n'a fallu qu'une
heure 45 et 3,7 vraiment sec à
l'allemand de l'ouest pour assurer la
victoire de son pays l'eau des mares il
ne sait plus vraiment comment jouer mats
wilander et pourtant il y croit encore
même si à cet instant de la partie boris
becker même 6 2 6 0
même si l'allemand l'a littéralement
surclassé pendant deux sets
et pourtant en ce début de troisième set
le suédois jouent mieux il remporte sa
mise en jeu et réussit même à passer
quelques fois becker sur son propre
service
iman deux un côté suédois on repense à
la coupe mais becker lui aussi il pense
à 7 coups alors il ressort le grand jeu
comme face à hedberg il y a deux jours
au total
il va réussir 14s wilander et
littéralement ko résultats l'allemand
remporte cinq jeux consécutifs et
s'impose 6-2 6-0 6-2 en une heure 45
après graf et becker en individuel c'est
donc l'équipe toute entière qui triomphe
en cette fin d'année le tennis allemand
peut vraiment sourire à pleines dents
il nous reste encore à vous donner les
résultats des courses de cet après midi
très exactement du tiercé et du quarté +
vous allez voir les résultats s'inscrire
sur votre écran 17 15 12 407 francs 50
pour 5 francs vous ajoutez le neuf et
vous gagnez 1444 en 57 x sitôt siffler
tout de suite après le journal les
prévisions météo c'est important avec le
mauvais temps et la douceur de choses et
blanc à pierre non seulement pour deux
hommes et pour tous le début de cette
semaine de noël
tout de suite après le journal vous
retrouverez donc l'heure de vérité en
direct du palais royal de rabat vous
voyez d'ailleurs les images actuellement
derrière moi alors de vérité reçoit ce
soir sa majesté roi du maroc hassan ii à
20h35 environ donc et puis il bien
entendu après l'heure de vérité en fin
de programme c'est à dire aux alentours
de 23h15 vous retrouverez philippe
gassot pour les toutes dernières
informations de ce dimanche
quant à demain ici même à 20h pour
retrouverez hervé claude quant à moi je
vous retrouverai toute l'équipe du
week-end et avec beaucoup de plaisir
d'avant ce samedi proches au revoir
bonne semaine
bonsoir